this war on whistleblowers is not
ancillary to journalism but actually it
directly affects it and it's making it
much harder for the public to get the
information they need
hi I'm Zach Weiss molar for recent TV
we're here with Trevor Tim co-founder
and executive director of the freedom of
the press foundation a non-profit with
the mission to advance public interest
journalism increased transparency and
protect whistleblowers also on the board
of directors are some heavy hitters in
the world of media and politics such as
Glenn Greenwald Laura Poitras Daniel
Ellsberg John Cusack and recently NSA
whistleblower Edward Snowden Trevor
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me what are the overarching goals of
freedom of the press foundation what's
kind of the big vision for it well you
know this first got started about a year
and a half ago the original inspiration
for it was actually the WikiLeaks
financial blockade so you know back in
2010 when WikiLeaks started publishing
all of this classified information State
Department cables and war logs from
Afghanistan and Iraq the payment
processors Visa MasterCard and PayPal
all cut them off even though they were
fully protected by the First Amendment
and they were doing exactly what other
media organizations do all the time like
the New York Times Washington Post Wall
Street Journal you know they're always
publishing leaked information and they
are allowed to do so because of Supreme
Court precedent from over 40 years ago
and so we thought this was really an
injustice and kind of an end run around
the First Amendment where government
officials were able to unofficially
pressure private companies to kind of
financially strangle them into censoring
themselves
I think getting this big group of people
together we really wanted to make this a
much broader mission and about First
Amendment principles and kind of
bringing the First Amendment into the
21st century
we transcribed the Chelsea Manning trial
for the media to use after the
government wouldn't release their own
transcripts and now we're actually going
around installing secure drop which is
an open source whistleblower submission
system that can better help news
organizations use technology to get
documents from whistleblowers so you
said you're bringing the First Amendment
into the 21st century what are the big
changes that you see that needs to be
made we can again look at the WikiLeaks
example where they were cut off from
payment processors where they were kind
of looked at as this digital upstart
they
weren't you know this established
organization and they were treated
differently even though they were
essentially doing the same thing you
know the same can be said about sources
and whistleblowers who have been
prosecuted at a record rate under the
Obama administration
you know they've prosecuted eight
whereas all other administrations
combined had prosecuted three the
government is figured out that they
don't need to get reporters to testify
against their sources anymore or try to
force them to if they can just go to
email providers and phone call providers
and subpoena all of their contacts this
war on whistleblowers is not ancillary
to journalism but actually it directly
affects it and it's making it much
harder for the public to get the
information they need and again you know
hopefully we can use technology to help
that problem instead of only seeing it
hurt it you mentioned how PayPal and
Visa got squeezed and basically cut off
the funding for WikiLeaks what's your
solution to get around that problem
going forward on our website you can
donate to a variety of different
organizations all with one click whether
you pick WikiLeaks muck Rock the bureau
for investigative journalism National
Security Archive Center for Public
Integrity and on our website you can
pick if you want to donate to all of
them are some of them are one of them
and the donation will show up on your
credit card as freedom of the press
foundation but then we take the bundle
of money for each organization and send
it off to them at at different intervals
so I mean I got to say that seems like
that puts a target on you guys you're
the ones that are kind of funneling the
funds to what could be organizations
that piss off the government how are you
protecting yourselves well I mean we
have very good legal counsel in EF F the
good thing about this is that it's
perfectly legal having a big platform
with a bunch of great people with loud
voices on our board of directors that
hopefully would raise hell essentially
if we were ever cut off ourselves they
don't want to do that and certainly we
wouldn't want to see that either before
you started this venture you worked at
the Electronic Frontier Foundation which
has really been at the forefront of a
lot of these privacy issues NSA spying
Fourth Amendment violations how has that
background informed what you're doing
here EF F has been suing the NSA for
years over over surveillance that was
exposed in 2005 and 2006 and you know it
was hard for us to get the public to pay
attention and it's really been
extraordinary seeing the sea change in
public opinion and the way they care
since Edward Snowden the First Amendment
is you know with without it you know we
wouldn't know any of this and so it's
really important that we maintain and
defend those rights especially when we
see that the government is attacking
them from all sorts of angles to get a
little bit more into the details what
are some of the specific tools that you
think more journalists or even potential
whistleblowers should know about Edward
Snowden part of the reason he went to
Laura Poitras was because she was versed
in encryption and knew how to use it
Glenn Greenwald jokes that he almost
lost the story of a generation because
he didn't know how to use PGP encryption
I think there's really been an awakening
in the past six months with reporters
and journalists but the problem is still
there they don't actually know what to
do they know that there is a problem but
they don't know how to solve it and so
we hope we can do that there's you know
a bunch of tools raising money for now
they're great you know tor the tor
browser bundle which anonymizes your web
traffic open whisper systems which makes
tech secure and red phone for Android
phones which provides end-to-end
encryption so that nobody but the
receivers on either end of the
conversation can see the message tails
most of the NSA reporters rely on it
frequently to do their work it's
basically an operating system that tries
to encrypt all of your traffic by
default a big part of the solution to
this surveillance problem is technology
you know we always look towards the
courts or the legislative branch but we
can take actions upon ourselves to
actually better protect ourselves in a
ways that the law necessarily can your
organization's focused on getting these
tools to journalists do you think that
there's eventually going to be a wider
market for encryption people have really
responded to the idea that privacy can
be something that is by design
that organizations who are marketing
communication tools can actually use
that as a pitch to get people to use
them you know we've seen a variety of
companies sprout up some good some bad
in the last six months and I think
that'll probably only continue as we
learn more about what the NSA does again
the problem is we just have to make them
easy to use so that they'll want to use
them and once we're there I think it'll
be easy
how did journalists whistleblowers or
anyone else who might be interested in
this get involved well our website is
Press Freedom Foundation org and so
right on the front page you'll see our
latest crowdfunding campaign about
encryption tools you know our you can
find secure drop on our front page as
well to find out more information if
you're a media organization and want us
to help come and install it for you you
can find our contact page there you know
I would encourage people to donate to
both the projects we're supporting in us
you know we're a young organization we
only started a year and a half ago and
so you know it's gonna take a lot of
people to help solve those problems so
we hope that we can get there and be
part of the solution charter Tim thank
you very much for coming in thanks a lot
for reason TV I'm Zach why smaller